You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost! Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water.
The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. Confronting a monster, realizing you can fly, running into your ninth grade teacher while you're not wearing pants.
The characters and situations we encounter in our dreams can be exhilarating, surprising, terrifying, even mundane. But where do dreams and nightmares come from and what, if anything, do they mean? Those questions have interested philosophers and mystics for centuries. In recent decades, scientists have begun to explore them as well. Today we're going to talk to one of those scientists about questions such as why do we dream? Why do some people remember their dreams in detail, like me, while others don't remember them at all? Can exploring our dreams offer us insight into our waking lives?
What are lucid dreams and can you train yourself to have one? What about sleep paralysis? And what about nightmares? Why do they occur? How common are they? And is there any way to treat them if they're interfering with your sleep and your mental health? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Antonio Zadra, a professor of psychology at the University of Montreal, and a researcher at the Center for Advanced Research in Sleep Medicine.
He is interested in all kinds of questions about nightmares and dreams, including how dreams relate to waking life and whether dreams have a function. He's also studied lucid dreams, recurrent dreams, and parasomnias, such as sleepwalking. Dr. Zadra holds an MA in experimental psychology and a PhD in clinical psychology from McGill University. He's published more than 100 research articles and book chapters on dreams and parasomnias and is the co-author of the book, When Brains Dream, Understanding the Science and Mystery of Our Dreaming minds. Dr. Zadra, thank you for joining me today. Thank you for having me. Pleasure to be here. I want to start our conversation by putting this right up front. I have always had extremely
vivid and convoluted dreams, which I often post about on social media to the vast amusement of my friends. And I often feel as if I'm more creative asleep than awake. So it's hard for me to fathom people who say they never dream or never remember their dreams. Is that possible? Are there people who are really not dreaming or do they just not remember them? Well, for the vast majority of people, the answer is that they never remember their dreams. And the reason we know that is that we can take people who claim they never dream, bring them into a sleep lab, wake them up at particular sleep stages throughout the night, particularly out of what is known as rapid eye movement sleep or REM sleep, during which our most vivid and narratively driven emotional
dreams take place. And if we waken up then, and especially in that particular type of REM sleep, known as phasic REM sleep, where there's more eye movements, a bit more body twitching, and over 80% of the time, these people go, oh my gosh, I was dreaming. I remember this and this. So we think that really everyone dreams, but there is great variability in how often we remember our dreams. And we also need to keep in mind that. that even the dreams we do remember, by and large, unless we tell them to someone or write them down, those memories fade pretty quickly. So you might have a pretty interesting, bizarre dream you remembered one morning,
but by lunch hour maybe it's just the core of it that remains, and by a day or two later, it might have almost entirely washed away, except for some maybe core details. Where do those memories go as compared to other memories? I mean, do we have any idea why dream memories dissipate so quickly? Well, that's debated. But one idea is that dreams, in and of themselves, are not generated to be remembered. And so that is why we have difficulty remembering our dreams.
And many people who do remember the dreams, even every morning, if you think that you have anywhere like maybe an hour and a half to two hours, just a REM sleep where our most vivid dreaming takes place every single night you go to bed. And we know you also have dreams in other phases of sleep. So you're spending several hours a night immersed in various kinds of dream worlds, of which you might remember just a few minutes every morning. And those memories, like I mentioned earlier, tend to fade. So we think that one reason is if you were to encode your dream experiences as vividly as your waking ones,
your mind would be a mess because it would be hard to disentangle what was real, what is not real. And there's actually some conditions, including some sleep disorders such as narcolepsy, where people do encode their dream memories as vividly, and at times even more vividly than their waking life experiences, and they, lo and behold, have trouble deciphering, did that really happen? Did my neighbor's daughter really die in an accident? Or did I dream that?
And if you have hours of that nightly, it becomes really problematic. If we believe maybe that some animals, other mammals that also have REM sleep dream, they have no one to teach them what a dream is, what is imagination, perception, reality. And so if you're a lion, just dreamt that you hunted out a zebra and you're eating it and you wake up and a there's no zebra,
B, you're hungry. Like, how do you make sense of that world? And so it's probably easier never to remember them and that later on if we talk about the functional dreams, that's also why we think that the functional dreams, if they have one, happens online as they are unfolding, regardless if you remember them or not. So that is a $64,000 question, the function of dreams. How much do we know about why we dream? A lot and very, very little. I say a lot because there are literally dozens of ideas and theories, but where dreams come from and why we have them and dreams and premonitions, dreams in health,
dreams and emotion regulation, and why did they evolve. But in terms of hard science, empirical evidence, these models are hard to test. But we are like in many other sciences, including neurosciences, including our understanding of why we sleep, making considerable progress. And we got to remember that not that long ago, we still didn't really have good ideas of why we sleep. How do people's dreams relate to what is happening in their waking lives and can exploring that question be a useful tool for therapists? I think it can be. I think it can be, a very useful tool for therapists. We do know that when we look at people's dreams, especially a series of dreams, when you have 10, 15, 20, 30 dreams of an individual over a certain period of time,
you can often start seeing patterns in them. What are the main emotions? Where do they take place? What kind of social interactions do they have? Are they friendly, aggressive? They might notice that when Peter's in your dream or your exes in your dream, you're always frustrated, or you're angry or you're joyful. So sometimes there is emotions associated with certain characters. So that's just to say that there are patterns we can observe in people's dreams that fluctuate as a function of our circumstances. But dreams can also be viewed as embodiments of our ongoing concerns, preoccupations.
And so we see that in many levels. We see that in the dreams of people grief dreams after they've lost a loved one. We see that in people who are trying to stop vicious cycles of drug or other alcohol consumption or other substances, when people are having relapses, in people with suicidal ideation, and people who suffer from depression. And people who have even exciting events on the horizon. It could be a wedding, could be a new job, could be moving to a new city. But these stressors or apprehensions or concerns we have about it, am I making the right decision? is this good for me, often get played sometimes, or oftentimes metaphorically, in our dream. So an individual dream might look, oh, bizarre and meaningless, but you start paying attention
to more of them and when they are happening, then I think they shine a light into what's on our minds, what is bothering us, and the kinds of emotions that we are presently dealing with. And probably this is best exemplified, of course, in an extreme format. in trauma survivors and how various kinds of traumas are reflected in people's dreams, including bad dreams and nightmares. Yeah, you know, I wanted to get to nightmares. And since you raised them, why don't we jump there right now? Because I know that you do study nightmares.
And I'm just wondering, how common are they? And do we know what percentage of most dreams are nightmares? Those are excellent questions. So, first of all, there's maybe about five. to 8% of the general adult population who complain of nightmares, who say they have a problem with nightmares. So they are quite common. And to have the occasional nightmare, to have a few per year or so, that is absolutely the norm. Actually, I would say people say I've never had nightmares and they're probably never remembering their dreams. And that might happen. But they're in a minority. About
85% or so of people say they have them at least on occasion. So they are quite common. And what proportion of our dreams are nightmares? That is a trickier one to answer, but we've done a study where we collected close to 10,000 home dream reports. So these are not laboratory dreams. These are the dreams people tend to remember when they wake up in the morning. And so these are the dreams that we tend to have, which are, again, the more bizarre, emotionally laden, narratively driven. And roughly 3% of these 10,000 dreams we looked at from several hundred people were nightmares. And about another 10% we could call bad dreams.
They were highly negative dreams with all kinds of negative emotions, fear, but also disgust, jealousy, confusion, sadness, but usually not as intense as those that we find in nightmares. So a sizable proportion of our, at least our home dreams, contain these highly negative intense emotions. So most of the studying that you do would be in a lab, right? But for nightmares, I mean, you can't really put somebody in a lab, tell them go to sleep and have a nightmare. Is the only way to study nightmare through self-report?
No, you can study nightmares in a lab as well. The challenge, again, it really depends what question do you want to answer. So if I want to know what's going on in terms of your electrical brain activity, when you're having a nightmare, what goes on in terms of your respiration rate or heart rate? Does it shoot up when you're having a nightmare? Then that I have to pretty much do in a lab, ideally. I also, if I want to know, is it happening early in the night in REM sleep, later in the night? So depending on the questions you have, the lab might be a good place to do it.
The challenge with studying nightmares in the lab is that even frequent nightmare sufferers rarely have nightmares in the lab. And so they actually often want to come back to the lab because they go, I didn't sleep that well in spite of all the electrodes and so on in a long time. And so that's an interesting observation in and off itself. And we think that one explanation for this is they know they were being monitored over the night. They know someone is watching over them. And that might be something that has a positive impact on them.
and they feel maybe less vulnerable with respect to their nightmares. Now, if I want to know what are the most common themes we find in people's nightmares, how often they occur over periods of weeks or months in some individuals, then it's not practical to have someone come in your sleep lab and sleep there for three weeks consecutively. So then these home dream studies are better. And if we want to know the relationship between, do you have your nightmares or bad dreams because of stress,
then I can have you keep a home dream diary and every day complete some questionnaires about maybe your stress levels, emotionally salient events you've had. And so then it allows us to plot over time the occurrence of nightmares and what's going on in terms of your waking life, waking stressors, psychological adjustments, and so on. So both methods are useful. They're complementary. It really depends what are you trying to answer in terms of a clinical or research question. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199, and entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low
prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. Loss supplies last. Pricing valid May 14th or May 27th. U.S. only exclusions apply. See homedepot.com slash price match for details. What are the treatments that are available for people who have frequent nightmares? Maybe they're suffering from PTSD or there's something else that's going on in their lives and it's become really, it interferes with their daily waking life. How do you treat people who are in that situation?
I'm really happy that you're asking this question because we do have, very effective treatments for most kinds of nightmares, and it's true for war veterans, trauma-related survivors, children who have nightmares. They're easy, relatively easy to implement. They're highly effective. And unfortunately, many people who suffer from nightmares, including mental health professionals who treat all kinds of psychological issues, are unaware of their existence.
And so people and many professionals think there's not much you can do about nightmares. Second is many people think, oh, yeah, well, if I'm going to work on my nightmares, then the mental health professional is going to want me to go explore my childhood, my relationship with my parents, what's going on. And I don't have the energy for that. And so here, erroneously, nightmares are viewed as a symptom of something else. But you can also view nightmares as a primary sleep disorder, a disorder which we can treat directly as a problem in and of itself without having necessarily to go explore any presumed or underlying
causes and that you can have a positive impact. People end up sleeping better. And many say they are sleeping so much better since they no longer have nightmares or have them a lot less frequently, that they feel more energized, more self-confident. And then if they are interested in doing other forms of psychotherapy or addressing much more ingrained, older underlying issues for other reasons, they feel they have the energy to do so. And the same thing happens with trauma-related nightmares. So what are these treatments? There are mainly two. The number one recommended treatment. When I say recommend it. It's by people who work in the field, the American Academy of Sleep Disorders, again, because it's where we have the best evidence of randomized control trials, good
outcome, follow up. One of these treatments, the most common one, is called imagery rehearsal therapy, which in a nutshell is, when you have a nightmare, take the time to reimagine it while changing something in it. Change whatever feels right to you. Now often people will say, oh, you're supposed to change the ending to something triumphant, whatever. Now, you can do that, but you should not tell the people what to change. And some of them will change the ending. Some will change the beginning. Some will change some minor details. Some will make a friend or supernatural character appear and save them at the end. But there's part of the exercise of making this decision and working through how you want to change it and how it'll unfold,
that's probably empowering. And for many people, it's the first time that they look at their nightmares, not as something that they are helpless to do anything about, but the idea that they can manipulate them, change something, something really new to them. So in essence, the exercise is this. It can be adapted to children through drawings. you can have them draw a different version of their nightmare.
And anytime you have these nightmares, that's what you're supposed to do. Take a few minutes of your day, engage in these imagery exercises, and then imagine the nightmare in a different format. Now, the sessions can certainly be more complicated than that. Some people have trouble using active imagination. Some people have at first, have trouble trying to imagine these nightmares, especially if they remind them, a very painful events. And so sometimes there's exercises you need to do, relaxation exercises, imagery exercises. So start by learning how to imagine a positive scene. So sometimes there's these things they need to do. But by and large, imagery rehearsal therapy,
as I say, is something relatively simple, no real side effects. We're talking just about a few sessions. You give these people these tools, which they go and practice at home. It can be done individually in groups. And by and large, there's clinical improvements observed anywhere between 75, 85% of those populations, which is really quite an astounding figure. We have very few treatments in psychology, for anything. For anything with that level of success. The other treatment is a pharmacological one and is really only recommended for people who have severe cases of post-traumatic stress disorder. And for instance, if we're talking about people in combat areas, they might not have access to someone to do imagery rehearsal therapy, what have you, but they might have
access to medication. And we know people who suffer from post-traumatic stress disorder in their sleep, a key neurotransmitter hormonal modulator, known as norapinephrine, their levels become abnormally high during their sleep, including REM sleep, which is probably why they have dreams that replay the traumatic events. Now, you're mentioning at the outset, Kim, that you have these, when you remember your dreams, it'd be very bizarre and so on. And that's true of many people. Our dreams rarely replay our events of waking life as they occurred.
There's often there's twist. The setting is wrong. The characters are wrong. There things are blended or it starts off in this place and then goes to another one. And that's how dreams are constructed. People who have PTSD tend to replay these negative, strong, traumatic events from their lives. And we think part of that are due to these imbalances in their neurotransmitter systems. Prazazin, this pharmacological agent, which is actually originally developed for hypertension,
for high blood pressure, has as a side effect, if you want, normalizes, brings back down to normal levels, these levels of noraphyran in your brain, particularly during REM sleep. And that, we think, inhibits the formation of these episodic memories in our dreams, memories of events as they happened. So regardless what kind of nightmares you have, trauma-related, stress-related, and there are some many what we call idiopathic, just a fancy word, meaning we don't know why you have them. And again, imagery rehearsal therapy works very well, first-line recommendation. And again, in cases where access to these kinds of treatments aren't available,
Prazacin for more trauma-related ones is a plan B. So there are things people can do. And then there's other things. There's relaxation exercises. There's something called lucid dreaming, becoming aware that you're dreaming. But these tend to be harder to teach, not as effective. And so when I see people working on these new treatments, for nightmares, sometimes honestly, I think, why? We already have something that's really simple
and we know works really, really well. You mentioned lucid dreaming a minute ago, and also, as you were describing imagery rehearsal therapy, it sounded to me a lot like the self-training that you might try to do if you wish to have lucid dreams. Can you talk about what that means to have a lucid dream, why people are interested in doing it? lucid dreams essentially are dreams in which you are aware that you are dreaming while you're still in the dream. And the people are interested in either learning to have lucid dreams or having them more often because they're associated with an idea of being able to influence or control the outcome of your dream. And so people think it'd be great if I could soar through the air tonight in my dream
or meet person X or Y or I do these activities and so on. Now, that can happen, but people often underestimate how tricky and hard it is to have these kinds of lucid dreams. So before I was mentioning nightmares, some people at the very end of their nightmare might go, oh my gosh, yeah, this is just a dream, and they wake themselves up. So were they lucid? Sure, for, you know, one and a half seconds. That's all that that's it.
On the other hand, you have people who can become aware they are dreaming. They know where they are asleep. I'm visiting my girlfriend or I'm in my apartment. I'm sleeping here. I got an exam tomorrow. So they have access to some kind of memories of their daytime lives. And then to various degrees, they can use this awareness to try to manipulate or change how the dream unfold. So you might be having a dream where you're at work, you're stuck in traffic, you're in a class, something that is sort of mundane.
You want something more exciting. Then you can try to transport yourself through lucid dreaming to an outdoor cafe in Paris to the moon, to whatever. Now, that might work. That might not work. And so becoming lucid, I tell people, that's the easy step. Becoming aware that you're dreaming, that's the easy step. The heart step is how do you? go about using this awareness to change the dream if you want to do it and to do it in a way that
you don't get overly excited so that you wake up. We're talking about nightmares and often people wake up because the emotions they feel in them become overwhelming. They overwhelm their system. They're so scared by what's about to happen. They wake up. But being overenthus, overjoyed in your dream can have the same impact. On the other hand, it's very easy also to freak get that you're dreaming and to fall back into a non-lucid dreaming. And so you're sort of on a tight rope. On one side, you get overly excited. You wake up. On the other one, you're a bit too detached, and you lose your lucid, your dream lucidity. So all I'm saying is that it's great fun. Lucid dreaming is actually the reason I got interested in sleep in dreams is from really wild lucid
dream I had while I was in college, the first dream I ever wrote down. And that's the reason. what sparked my interest in all of this. So it literally was a life-changing dream because it changed my career path or what I was aiming for. But it's not as simple as many people or as easy as many people make it out to be. I want to change gears for a minute now and talk about sleepwalking or somnambulism, which is a great word. I have a really good friend who at one point in her life, she would go to bed, go to sleep. And at some point, she'd get it. get up, she'd unlock her apartment door, she'd vacuum her living room in her sleep and then go back to bed. No consciousness she'd get up in the morning and the vacuum cleaners in the living room,
like when the door is open and she realized that she was doing this. What makes people sleepwalk? Why do some people sleepwalk and do wild things and some people never sleepwalk at all? That's an excellent question. So we know that most people who sleepwalk have a genetic predisposition for the disorder, for sleepwalking. So it tends to, no pun intended, run in families. Now, the kinds of behaviors people engage in are really very variable. Some people have fairly mundane episodes of sleepwalking. They might just sit up in bed, point out a wall, mumble, play with their bed sheets, maybe get up and then go to sleep on the couch, whatever. Some, you know, they'll wake up somewhere else. But,
they're not in any risk of injuring themselves, injuring others. You mentioned your friend who would go up and who would get up and vacuum. That'd be good. That's, you know, that's really effective use of her parisomnia. You know, maybe they tag on, you know, doing laundry and so on and folding. Yeah. That'd be a good use. So some people do engage in these activities.
We've had musicians, even from local orchestras here, who were sleepwalkers. And during their episodes, would play, would take out their. musical instruments are playing it. So, you know, you're hearing a cello at two in the morning of your neighbor is and all that thrill. On the other hand, there's people who put themselves in situations of danger. They can unlock the door, leave the house. I'm in Montreal. February here is pretty cold, snow, ice. They might leave their home just in their underwear or in their pajamas. Get severe frostbite cross the street. Risk of being hit by an automobile. Some have very agitated episode, they think there might be an intruder in the house. People have
unintentionally, of course, spat on their children because they did not recognize their children during their episodes. And some people have manipulated firearms, knives during their episodes, have gone up on roofs. Again, so they're putting themselves in situations of danger. And so it's the ones who have these more agitated, complex episodes who are the ones who are most likely to come to a sleep clinic. So there's a genetic predisposition. And then why do you have an episode on Tuesday, not on Wednesday? Why do you stay two weeks without having any? And then you have three in one week. And we know that having irregular sleep schedules, being sleep deprived is one factor that contributes to why you have it one night and not another. And the reason is that sleepwalking occurs in
slow-wave sleep, our deepest stage of sleep. We tend to have most of it in the first third of the night. But if you are sleep-deprived either acutely because you're doing shift work, because you stayed up all night to study, what have you, when you go back to bed, that is the stage of sleep that will come back with the biggest rebound. Not all stages of sleep resurface equally. So that one has priority. And because episodes occur out of slow-way sleep, if you have a lot more of it and it's more intense, you're more likely to have a sleepwalking episode. Many will say also if they are in periods of stress, it doesn't matter what the stressor is, could be a financial stress, could be a good stress.
You're going to give birth to a child, you're starting a new job, you, anything that stresses you can also facilitate the occurrence of sleepwalking. And incidentally, sleepwalking takes place. the people are not fully awake, nor are they fully asleep. When we look at what's going on in the brain during the episodes, some neural circuits are fast asleep, and some of them are partially awake. And depending what circuits are doing what,
you have agitated episodes, calm episodes, people talking, understanding, people are really agitated when I need to get out of the house because they think there's an immediate danger. because there's a noise in the room, a disturbance, they're changing positions in bed. Normally, a non-sleepwalker might just wake up. There's a bang in the room, for instance, a sudden noise. For sleepwalkers, their brain gets stuck transitioning from slow way sleep to wakefulness.
It gets sort of stuck halfway. Some parts of the brain are awake. Others are still asleep, and that what gives rise to this state. And that's why you're mentioning a friend who would vacuum. Well, if you're vacuuming, you've got to be able to see your bedroom door and open it and see where the vacuum is. And then to be able to find the electrical cord and plug it in. So you are interacting with your environment. On the other hand, your logic might be completely off.
You look at the sleepwalker do something and you go, my gosh, what are they doing? and it makes sense once you know what is going through their mind. So the other example I like to give is someone who during the episode sees his dog, which is on his bed, and his real dog was on his bed, jumps out of bed, grabs the dog, runs to the bathroom, turns on the shower, and throws the dog under the shower head. Now, again, the spouse is like, what are you doing? but he had seen little flames shooting off the dog's fur.
当你看着梦游者做一些事情时，你会想，天哪，他们在干什么？一旦你知道他们脑子里在想什么，这就说得通了。所以我喜欢举的另一个例子是，某人在发作期间看到他的狗在床上，而他的真狗也确实在床上，于是他从床上跳下来，抓起狗，跑到浴室，打开淋浴喷头，把狗扔到了淋浴喷头底下。现在，同样地，配偶会觉得，你在干什么？但他看到狗的毛皮上闪烁着微小的火焰。
So if you think your dog is on fire, well, that action makes perfect sense. So sleepwalking also very interesting because it raises all kinds of questions about the mind, consciousness, volition, are we responsible for our acts? Do we remember them? There's all kinds of also medical, legal implications. So a fascinating to me, sleep disorder. You know, it sounds a lot like migrating birds that can put half of their brain to sleep and they can continue flying. I mean, have you found similarities in that respect?
所以如果你以为你的狗着火了，那么这种行为就完全说得通了。因此，梦游也非常有趣，因为它引发了关于心智、意识、意志力的各种问题，我们是否对自己的行为负责？我们还记得它们吗？这里面还有各种医学和法律上的含义。所以在我看来，这是一个令人着迷的睡眠障碍。你知道，这听起来很像候鸟，它们可以让半个大脑睡觉，然后继续飞行。我的意思是，你在这方面发现过相似之处吗？
Well, for the migratory birds you mention, or dolphins in whales who also have what's known as unihemispheric sleep, which is half the brain, one hemisphere sleeps at a time. migratory birds is what allows them to fly days on end as they're crowcing the oceans. For example, some dolphins, they need to surface to breathe. And so the reason they had unihemispheric sleep is that it allows part of their brain to sleep and the other one to go, oh, okay, it's time to surface, we need to breathe. And so it is analogous in the sense that sleep and wakefulness are co-occurring or co-execurring. existing inside the same brain at the same time.
嗯，对于你提到的候鸟，或者海豚和鲸鱼，它们也拥有所谓的半球睡眠，也就是每次只有半个大脑、一个半球在睡觉。候鸟的这种睡眠方式让它们能够在穿越海洋时连续飞行数日。例如，有些海豚需要浮出水面呼吸。因此，它们拥有半球睡眠的原因是，它允许大脑的一部分睡觉，而另一部分则在想，哦，好吧，是时候浮出水面了，我们需要呼吸。从某种意义上说，这是类似的，因为睡眠和清醒同时存在于同一个大脑中。
Just that in the case of migratory birds, some species of ducks and other mammals, it has an evolutionary basis. It works. Here it seems to be a bit of a breakdown in how these systems, which are very complicated to work. And if we think transitioning from wakefulness to sleep to back from wakefulness is things we take for granted, but it's like going under anesthesia. I mean, you lose consciousness, and there's a lot that goes on in your brain to allow you to fall asleep and then to bring you back into wakefulness.
只是对于候鸟、某些种类的鸭子和其他哺乳动物来说，这有着进化的基础。它行得通。而在这里，这似乎是这些极其复杂的工作系统出现了一些故障。如果我们认为从清醒过渡到睡眠，再从睡眠回到清醒是我们视为理所当然的事情，但这就好比进行麻醉。我的意思是，你失去了意识，你的大脑中发生了许多事情，才能让你入睡，然后又让你恢复清醒。
And a lot can go wrong in there, as many people with all kinds of sleep disorders, starting with insomnia, unfortunately, no. But yes, what you mentioned are interesting parallels that show us that having sleep, wakefulness coexist in the brain is something that we can naturally observe in other species. So last question, I want to ask you about your concerns that I know you've expressed around dream hacking, where advertisers try to work their products into our dreams. Can you talk about that? How well does it work? Is this something that we should be worried about? Okay. So it's not something that is ongoing now.
在这个过程中可能会出很多问题，正如许多患有各种睡眠障碍的人一样，不幸的是，从失眠开始，对吧？但是，是的，你所提到的有趣的相似之处向我们表明，让睡眠和清醒在脑海中并存是我们可以在其他物种身上自然观察到的现象。所以最后一个问题，我想问你关于你所表达的对“梦境黑客”的担忧，我知道广告商试图将他们的产品植入我们的梦中。你能谈谈那个吗？这有多大效果？这是我们应该担心的事吗？好的。所以这不是现在正在发生的事情。
And as far as I know, I haven't been paid by some secret sleep advertiser to say that. But there is this growing technology that is being used for good, for treating nightmares, for mental health issues, known as dream engineering. And dream engineering is the use of various technologies and techniques to try to influence and manipulate dream content. And it can work quite well. But like many things, many technologies that work well, they can be used for different reasons. And so we do have enough evidence to believe that it wouldn't be that far-fetched to use some techniques or develop variations of them to engage in product placement while we dream, of which we may not even remember having dreamt of that.
据我所知，我并没有被某个秘密的睡眠广告商收买才这么说。但这种不断增长的技术正在被用于好事，用于治疗噩梦、心理健康问题，被称为“梦境工程”。梦境工程是利用各种技术和手段来试图影响和操纵梦境内容。它的效果可以相当好。但就像许多事情一样，许多运行良好的技术，它们可以出于不同的原因而被使用。因此，我们确实有足够的证据相信，利用某些技术或开发其变体在我们做梦时进行植入式广告并非遥不可及的事情，而我们甚至可能不记得自己曾梦见过那些。
And these can be images that are implanted, but it can be auditory stimuli that are presented in our sleep. And now as more and more people have sleep trackers, have different monitors during their sleep at home, various wearable devices, devices also that record your sleep. I mean, any sounds, which can be really useful because you want to know, are you snoring, are you not snoring? And you can have these apps that will record you. But there's nothing precluding these apps from sending you stimuli. And if you're sleeping with the sleep wearable, then the company might know when you're, REM sleep when you're in deep sleep and so know in which phase of sleep, these stimuli might be most effective to influence your choices, behaviors, purchases. And so are we there now? No, we're not.
这些可以是植入的图像，也可以是在我们睡眠中呈现的听觉刺激。现在，随着越来越多的人在家中使用睡眠追踪器、不同的睡眠监测器、各种可穿戴设备，还有记录睡眠的设备。我的意思是，任何声音，这真的很有用，因为你想知道，你打呼噜了吗，你没有打呼噜吗？你可以使用这些应用程序来为你录音。但没有什么能阻止这些应用程序向你发送刺激。如果你带着睡眠穿戴设备睡觉，那么公司可能会知道你什么时候处于快速眼动睡眠，什么时候处于深睡眠，从而知道在睡眠的哪个阶段，这些刺激可能最有效地影响你的选择、行为、购买行为。那么我们现在到了这一步吗？不，我们还没有。
Could we be there in the near future? Certainly. And there's at least 40 sleep and dream researchers who are worried enough that we all signed this letter petitioning to put guardrails. we should have one last refuge where we are not exposed to advertisement, and that is our land of dreams. My so-to-speak nightmare is one day where I'll be able to say, Kim, give me $10 a month, and I'll guarantee you, you know, add-free dreams, so you can opt out, right? I think that would be a horrible world to be in, and so we're bombarded sufficiently, and personal data, collected sufficiently throughout our waking lives and activities that we think that sleep and dreams, which also have very important functions, should be off limits.
我们能在不久的将来达到这一步吗？当然可以。至少有40名睡眠和梦境研究人员感到足够的担忧，以至于我们都签署了这份请愿书，呼吁建立护栏。我们应该拥有最后一个不受广告影响的避难所，那就是我们的梦境之地。我所谓的噩梦就是有一天我可以说，金，给我一个月10美元，我向你保证，你知道的，无广告的梦，这样你就可以选择退订，对吧？我认为那将是一个可怕的世界，我们受到的轰炸已经足够多了，在我们的清醒生活和活动中，个人数据也被收集得足够多了，我们认为同样具有非常重要功能的睡眠和梦境应该被视为禁区。
Especially since there's good evidence that you can do these manipulations that can impact people's choices, even for like a brand of candy, for instance, has been shown to work. but they have no idea why they change from like smarties to Skittles, things of that nature. But it's because of stimulation presented during their sleep. And so I think that anything that can change people's views, preferences, without them knowing why, that is the key to me is something should be off limits. So like I said, it's not here now, but we think we should maybe be proactive and vigilant And if we think what advertisers are willing to spend for 30 seconds of advertising during the Super Bowl
特别是由于有充分的证据表明，你可以进行这些能够影响人们选择的操纵，甚至对于某种糖果品牌，例如，已经被证明是有效的。但他们根本不知道为什么他们从聪明豆（smarties）换成了彩虹糖（Skittles），诸如此类的事情。但这都是因为在他们睡眠期间呈现了刺激。因此，我认为任何能够改变人们的看法、偏好而又让他们不知道原因的事情——这对我来说是关键——都应该是禁区。所以就像我说的，它现在还不存在，但我们认为我们也许应该采取积极主动和警惕的态度，如果我们想想广告商愿意为超级碗期间30秒的广告花多少钱
or during some highly rated shows or podcasts or what have you, how much are they willing to spend if they can have a technology that can access your mind for a couple hours every night? Well, it turns out a lot. And if researchers with meager memes, like many sleep researchers in the world, can do these various simple experiments if companies with a lot of means and a lot of resources could certainly develop techniques that are much more effective and potentially much more harmful depending on how you view it. So yeah, so we are concerned more about what lies down the road
或者在一些收视率极高的节目、播客或诸如此类的节目中，如果他们能够拥有一种每天晚上都能进入你大脑几个小时的技术，他们愿意花多少钱？事实证明，这笔钱非常多。如果资源微薄的研究人员，就像世界上许多睡眠研究人员一样，可以做这些各种简单的实验，那么拥有大量资源和大量资源的公司肯定可以开发出更有效、并且根据你的看法可能更有害的技术。所以，是的，我们更担心的是未来会发生什么
and then we should be proactive than 10 years down the road going, oh my gosh, this is horrible and how do we get out of it, which is what we're basically doing now with many other technological developments. Well, I'm glad to hear that you're working against that. I think we all have enough to worry about in life right now. So, Dr. Zadra, I want to thank you for joining me today. It's been really interesting. Oh, it's been fabulous exchanging with you. Thank you for having me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave a review. For those of you who want to know more about psychology and the work of APA,
而不是10年后面带惊恐地说，天哪，这太可怕了，我们该怎么摆脱它，这基本上就是我们在许多其他技术发展上目前正在做的事情。好吧，我很高兴听到你正在为此努力。我认为我们现在生活中要担心的已经够多了。所以，扎德拉博士，我要感谢你今天能来。这真的很有趣。哦，与你交流太棒了。谢谢你邀请我。你可以在我们的网站 speakingof psychology.org 或在苹果、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方找到往期的《心理学闲谈》（Speaking of Psychology）。如果你喜欢我们听到的内容，请订阅并留下评论。对于那些想要更多了解心理学和 APA 工作的人，
you can join us as a supporter. You don't have to be a psychologist. The benefits include a subscription to our award-winning magazine, Monitor on Psychology, as well as discounts on our books and other publications. So if psychology is your passion, or if you just want to know more about the science, you can become a supporter by visiting at.apa.org slash speaking. That's att. dot apa.org slash speaking. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Warnerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Did you know if your windows are bare, indoor temperatures can go
你可以作为支持者加入我们。你不需要是一名心理学家。福利包括订阅我们屡获殊荣的杂志《心理学观察》（Monitor on Psychology），以及购买我们的书籍和其他出版物的折扣。因此，如果心理学是你的热情所在，或者你只是想了解更多关于这门科学的知识，你可以访问 at.apa.org/speaking 成为支持者。也就是 att.apa.org/speaking。如果你对未来的播客有意见或想法，你可以发电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。心理学闲谈由李·沃纳曼（Lee Warnerman）制作。感谢美国心理学协会的收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。你知道如果你的窗户光秃秃的，室内温度可以上升
up 20 degrees? Get ahead of summer with custom window treatments like solar roller shades from blinds.com and save up to 45% off during the Memorial Day Early Access sale. Whether you want to DIY it or have a pro handle everything, we've got you. Free samples, real design experts, and zero pressure. Just help when you need it. Shop up to 45% off site wide right now during the Early Access Memorial Day sale at blinds.com. Rules and restrictions apply. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
20度吗？通过来自blinds.com的定制窗饰（如太阳能卷帘）提前迎接夏天，并在阵亡将士纪念日早期特惠期间享受高达45%的折扣。无论你想自己动手还是让专业人士处理一切，我们都能满足你。免费样品，真正的设计专家，零压力。在你需要的时候随时提供帮助。现在就在blinds.com的早期特惠阵亡将士纪念日促销中选购全场最高45%的折扣。规则和限制适用。此剧集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。